c'est notre génial idées ses fans et
bien se sont donné rendez-vous à
l'olympia les lettres rouges à son nom
sont affichés à l'entrée femmes se
retrouvent aujourd'hui dans cette salle
mythique qui a une place particulière
dans la carrière du chanteur johnny
hallyday sur la façade de l'olympia
c'est quand même historique ça s'est pas
produit qu'une fois 1 260 septième fois
que c'est comme ça et que ces allumés
comme ça la dernière fois ici c'était en
2000 à l'intérieur un musée éphémère
rassemble des tenues des motos des
guitares de johnny aujourd'hui c'est un
documentaire sur leurs idoles que les
fans vont découvrir ce film est
l'occasion de retrouver la voix
puissante et l'énergie de cet incroyable
show man pour ce couple grand admirateur
de johnny ce sera le lieu de la demande
en mariage et on a des informations
complémentaires
oui alors ça a été trois séances on le
sait un midi 16 heures et 20 heures
d'ailleurs à 16 heures quand ils ont vu
défiler le générique et qui a vu le nom
de laetitia les remerciements parce que
c'est en fait c'est universal qui
organisait sa avec la maison et issia
bien sûr et dès qu'ils ont vu le nom de
laëtitia site et tout le monde a sifflé
et hué ça a été terrible
je trouve ça assez choquant en revanche
elle elle a débarqué à 20h et des
normales quelle histoire
alors c'est un a dit qu'il ya une
affaire de marchands des crues sur une
chaise longue oui c'est bizarre c'est le
micro qui en fait donc si vous voulez il
ya la visite de la loge de johnny
reconstituer et là c'était 100 euros
pour avec la costumière mal pourvu
s'emballe pour visiter la loge la
casquette 30 bal le t-shirt 25 le pull
bon ça s'est installé là bas tu partais
combat constate assez cher tu partent en
vacances qu'il faut garder ces qui a eu
tout de même beaucoup beaucoup d'émotion
mais alors vraiment hélas pour les fans
c'était quand même formidable j'ai vu
les réactions des fans disais qu'un
heureux de le revoir ce qu'on peut
reprocher toutefois c'est qu'il n'y ait
pas eu l'olympia tout de même puisque
c'était un hommage à la fois l'olympia
puis ce qu'ils vendaient un coffret
également spécial olympia à 150 balles
il aurait aucune image de sylvie vartan
alors qu'ils se sont rencontrés à
l'olympia un mon cher fait bien et qu'en
plus ils ont chanté ensemble en
septembre 2009 à l'olympia
et ça ça n'existe pas et les fans l'ont
reproché sein d'accor bamert si vous
voyez on avait un nombre initial
comment la barre merci à vous il vous
enverra bien sûr la semaine prochaine à
l'hommage à fabien lecoeuvre leur
propose laetitia lé un lieu dédié à l
idée est ce que c'est un musée c'est
l'occasion d' encore faire du pognon sur
johnny hallyday ou c'est quelque chose
de gratuit pour jean reno alors elle a
raison là c'est bien de faire quelque
chose de dédier à paris puisque
visiblement il y aura le corps va rester
à saint barth donc c'est compliqué
d'aller à saint barth ça coûte cher
donc il faut absolument un lieu dédié là
c'est un message qu'elle balance un peu
hidalgo 6 voilà c'est ça et je crois
qu'en fait il va le faire au score anne
hidalgo elle a déjà beaucoup de travaux
dans paris hidalgo frère d'alec un
casque de chantier et ronnie delgo des
gens pour la voir on va faire c'est se
réduire il serait dans le neuvième art
hidalgo elle est maire de paris où elle
est dans le bâtiment
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la tête de ma mère anne hidalgo en fait
à l'échelle de chaud des plages on est
là on va mettre du plat complet là tu me
fais le tu me fais tu mets du carrelage
un d'accord oui et des siècles fait des
gestes pour apaiser a dit qu'elle mettra
à disposition de ce musée s'il existe ou
les objets qui existe sur pascal et
donnerait pour lui ni chez son père les
fans vont être les entrées de lego
visiter nash son rôle mais moi je serai
les fans de johnny je regarderai des
concerts en qassam et la journée j'ai la
vsv il s'emballe pour les femmes mais
énorme
ouais c'est beaucoup mieux passé johnny
avait la rage abri la lola 150 euros
vers les malades comme attendait à 10
balles tu visites pas dans le cadre
entièrement d'accord sur les chaînes
d'info y sont tellement fiers d'avoir
découvert que c'était la 260e fois que
là c'est bien qu'ils sont douze mois
j'ai arrêté de compter à 49 hier matin
toutes les chaînes et 260e fois ma nana